i'll give you everything i [ __ ] have  every [ __ ] secret that pops into my  dome every tactic that i've got every  connection i can give you every hello i  can give you any acknowledgement i can  give you my three seconds attention when  we run into each other at an airport  answer you when i can  give you the best content that i can  give you the blueprint that got me here  when i can  produce invest in production of content  at scale try to [ __ ] extract  everything that's in my [ __ ] soul for  you for free you can keep your money i'm  playing for your admiration  and i want to earn it that's me  that's what i'm playing like i want to  be the great entrepreneur of this  generation there'll be people who make  more money than me there'll be people  that invent more  but nobody's going to give a [ __ ] about  their audience more